I have to say that this person has a
possibility of having evil intent
to speak with confidence like these
amazing personalities every single one
of these amazing speakers have taken the
same program with brother Muhammad
Muhammad arshad has helped develop all
of us it's extremely beneficial to do
this course definitely recommend this
course
dear friends I have to say that this
person has a possibility of having evil
intent this person could have a
possibility of having a [__] this person
doing these actions can it be truly for
the sake of Allah there's possibilities
it can and there's possibilities it
can't it's a 50 50 matter I'm not
talking about um
why am I not talking about him the
reason being is this problem sister the
person that I'm talking about can be a
male or a female and it can apply to any
of us for that matter I want to make
something very clear as you guys know
yesterday I released a video pertaining
to a female speaker called sister dunia
I don't really know I've seen some of
the videos I don't really know nothing
of her neither her ex-husband or
ex-husband or whatever that matter the
point here is the following there is a
massive growing phenomena of men being
attacked verbally physically we talk
about this day in doubt I don't regret
doing that video Even though some
brothers which I love may Allah bless
them and honor them I do take the advice
that in the sense where you you know I
should have taken I should take the
video down I'm still Consulting I do not
believe I should but if that changes if
I have wronged anybody be it sister
dunia for that matter be anyone for that
matter I will publicly repent apologize
and take the video down until I do that
but at the moment me and Mohammed are
preparing for a big debate so I'm
focusing on that but I wanted to do this
video because the video that I did about
brother Salman who is married to uh
sister Dunya the video the evidence will
like to me was very clear there's of
course two sides to the story and the
first story comes up I would make that
public as well but from what I saw and
person experience that I know for a
female speaker who uses foul language at
the f word for a speaker to be accusing
people of certain things but do not call
the police and certain voice recordings
which should not be released by the way
because they were private but at the end
of the day I want this video
specifically about Omar Suleiman a lot
of people look you need to understand
something I have no difference with a
lot of people well I would say a lot of
people a couple of people yeah and some
of them backstabbed me literally
backstabbed me now I can't come out one
day and imagine something comes out
about them and that arguments like
somebody's accusing them of zinner or
somebody's accused them of theft or this
time just because they have backstabs
myself I jump on the bandwagon and go
yeah I knew it I knew it this is
insincerity I would say no I would
defend their honor yes even if his
brother brother yeah he outright
backstabbed backstabbing we are dealing
with enemies in the front line he backs
them with no qualifications from his
armchair and many other people I don't
want to name but I can't be unjust yes
and question their sincerity I have
never ever questioned their sincerity I
don't mention the interviews by name why
Brothers there's people coming out and
saying outrageous stuff One Lie saying
stuff like I've heard like for example
which I'm going to come to my discussion
with um I spoke to him yes and when it
comes to the matter of Salman accusing
him that he didn't he wants to be quiet
because you know the community will
attack Etc there is no evidence to that
number one number two before people come
and say you know yeah just because I
have look I have Danny her kitchen's
number I speak to regularly he helps me
with a lot of stuff I have almost number
I speak to them yeah if it was done
against Daniel I can catch you all will
do the same thing but people are
crossing the lines and limits by
backbiting and slandering just because
you this agree on something no problem
what these brothers disagree with when
it pertains to the American Dua and the
imams ETC I believe there are valid
points I do not disagree with that there
are valid points there's valid criticism
and we enjoy the good and forbid evil
but we should do private in CR and off
that the publicness it has to be done if
the the actions are being done is in
public however nobody has a right to go
and start accusing them of oh for
example if they speak like this on in
public imagine what they do la this is
slander this is a slander this is an
accusation imagine me coming and saying
oh if if this Prophet did this therefore
imagine what he does in the private you
can't see that you are not allowed to
see that that is Haram how does that
fall into the guidance of the Sharia
that you are accusing an individual that
if they are doing something that you
deem not the appropriate argument saying
for example we have to be the true show
yeah some people unqualified individuals
yeah that need to go I'll play for the
Medina Medina fee if they can go back
and study yeah simple principles yeah
they deem that we are Phoenix in our
British crucial which is I bring me
evidence yes there is no evidence yeah
unless you hold an opinion that's come
but to say that is the opinion so if
people come and say oh imagine if
they're free mixing and sitting on sofas
opposite sisters imagine what they're
doing when the camera's off imagine what
they're doing when they're this is a
slander and people are back biting so
casually
the Quran and the Sunnah makes it so
clear when it comes to backbiting how
severe it is Brothers how do you guys so
loosely your tongues are so loose may
Allah I have my difference to certain
individuals I am very very very very
careful to backbiting very very careful
yeah unless somebody's done something
clear-cut of backstabbing not myself
many individuals then we would have to
say which is the conditions that this
person isn't known for this and we have
to warn against him this person is known
to doing this so the point is what we
can criticize and say this is wrong
doing this for example a message like in
a massage unneeded circumstances for
example for men and women to sit
intermingle Etc Joel Kane Etc you know
but the point is what that to go out and
start slandering and calling them names
slandering them calling them names and
saying oh this person does that this is
Haram I spoke to ustad Omar and he took
an oath by Allah this accusation by
Prophet Salman that he said oh that you
know if we speak about the sister the
community is going to turn against me
I've seen messages which is shown me
I've seen with my own eyes that he was
there for you brother Salman to the best
to his ability you need to understand as
individuals who are in the proximere we
would I wish our Superman that can help
everybody and some people have a
question you didn't see my brother I'm
not Superman I've got my family to look
after I'm trying to save myself the
point is understand that to accuse him
and make it seem and this whole
Nickelback contract that he was on it
was fake yes it was outright fake okay
he didn't do that he's made a very clear
token off by Allah that he's had no
communication yes with sister like since
six seven years ago or something like
that for that matter so we need to be
very very careful to jump on the
Battleground I know a lot of people are
going to be watching this and thinking
that I'm going to be attacking
honor I will defend it okay whoever it
is unjustly being accused and slandered
is Haram and we need to be very careful
brother sisters to jump on the bandwagon
Omar is not perfect neither am I he's
made mistakes we are human beings we
make mistake and the best of Sinners are
those who repent so how could people
hold something against an individual
when he is repented he's changed it he's
made videos vocalizing himself when it
comes to the lgbtqt issue yes he's not
perfect he might make many other
mistakes so do I so do you imagine I
stuck to your mistake that you've done
and not let go well why Allah
punish us severely I just want to say
that let's be very very careful Allah
you can have your differences you can
criticize you can say this is wrong good
without name calling without backbiting
without slandering can you not do video
refutation Brothers
where is the demander trying to advise
privately it doesn't work okay publicly
but in a specific demeanor I see videos
people are like
weird you you're giving your cookies to
the person you dislike the most and
you're not clear would you want to give
your goodies to a person you don't like
good to the people that you love on your
camera you're going to end up giving
your goodness to a person you dislike
make you make sense to me that's why
myself I'm very careful because if I
dislike this person for the sake of
Allah and they've wronged me I will
abstain from name calling and slandering
them because why should I give my
goodness to him am I mad am I crazy so
please brothers and sisters when it
comes to this please be very careful
assumptions like I said before you have
been wronged and whoever who has been
wronged I will stand for it and many
many brothers are going through this
that's the reason I've done that video
yeah and I stick by it until I change my
mind and you know speak to the people of
knowledge and then we're going to see
inshallah if needed I will take the
video then and do a public apology but
for now it is a well needed video I've
had Brothers messaging me Left Right
Center of what they're going through
Left Right Center Allah it's crazy times
let's be very very careful to our tongue
the prophet Muhammad said the one who
guarantees us between his lips and
what's between his legs I give him good
news of paradise do not let these lips
cause you to destruction inshallah like
one scholar said I have never breath had
been silent but many times I've
regretted speaking